hey francis do you need new investment
ideas no thanks i've got all my cash
tied up in venezuelan crypto ah how is
gringo coin doing it's pronounced
gringott coin my portfolio is now worth
a billion venezuelan bolivars now that's
about three quid then uh you're right i
should have got new investment ideas
well if you want to take back control of
your finances then fortune and freedom
is for you it was founded by nigel
farage who has over 40 years of
experience in finance and politics
fortune and freedom is published by
south bank investment research and is
for the investor looking to access a
wide range of informed opinions on lots
of different investing opportunities
their brilliant newsletter covers
everything from causes and the impact of
inflation to the rise of
cryptocurrencies gold investing and much
more besides through their daily news
commentary and special reports fortune
and freedom can give you more confidence
in making informed decisions about what
to do with your money simply go to
fortune and freedom dot com that's
fortune and freedom dot com and sign up
for a free newsletter that will help
your money work for you the link is in
the description
the critical thing is
the government
through ofcom the state will be deciding
what jokes it thinks you should be able
to hear and what jokes you shouldn't
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant and returning guest
today is the general secretary of the
free speech union here in the uk toby
young welcome back to trigonometry thank
you constantin thank you francis it's
been a while since we had you on the
show and look the free speech union has
been doing incredible work only a few
days ago one of our interns came in who
does a bit of reading and research for
us and he's at university at the moment
and he was telling us that at his
university uh some people were trying to
shut down some kind of event that was
going to happen that had something to do
with free speech or whatever and uh they
were considering shuttering down and
then they went actually if we do this
toby young's going to come along and
[ __ ] things up so uh and they they allow
things to carry on basically uh because
of that and you're making great stuff
you know doing great stuff on other
things how's it going with the free
speech union yeah it's going really well
um we've now got 9 000 plus members
we've got something like 17
employees um you know i'm working on it
you know pretty much full time um the
demand for our services you know is
almost limitless we've just launched um
an fsu in scotland so we've opened a
scottish office and we've put together a
really impressive um advisory council in
scotland you know we've got murdo fraser
former deputy leader of the conservative
group up there still an msp we've got um
jim silas former deputy leader of the
snp we've got some trade unionists we've
got some poets some writers some
intellectuals a huge cross-section of
people from you know every political
side all really concerned about the
erosion of free speech in scotland
particularly when the scottish hate
crime and public order scotland act is
activated it's got royal ascent but it
hasn't yet been activated when it's
activated that's going to make you know
free speech um uh under greater threat i
think in scotland than anywhere else in
europe yeah and we're going to talk
about the online harms bill for the uk
more broadly as well because that's
really important but from as an outside
observer you know francis and i we don't
have any direct involvement with the fsu
though we obviously support what you're
doing you're both on the advisor we
aren't advising we've given no advice
whatsoever which is true i haven't yet
for the massive
but it seems to me from the outside
watching that you keep winning battle
after battle you you defend people who
get cancelled or fired or whatever as i
said you are fostering a culture of
genuine respect for viewpoint diversity
in academia you're helping people
recover their reputation after they've
been unfairly smeared and attacked
do you feel that these
the the the sum of these battles being
won
is helping us win the war or are you
more hesitant about that i'm a little
more hesitant i mean i don't want to
sound too pessimistic and i think the
war is winnable um but it's not going to
be winnable particularly quickly it
feels like a kind of generational battle
rather than something that can be won
overnight um you know if you think about
the long march through the institutions
that's taken you know 70 years um so
it's not that surprising if people have
dedicated themselves to capturing you
know the commanding heights of the
cultural economy that those heights are
now captured and to recapture them or at
least to um decouple them from you know
this kind of these these kind of woke
cultists um
is not going to be something that can be
accomplished overnight you know i don't
think it'll take 70 years and i think
the presence of social media kind of
accelerates these cultural shifts so you
know it's possible um things may improve
a lot over the next five to ten years
and what made you start the free speech
union toby
it was partly my own experience of being
cancelled at the beginning of 2018 um i
was appointed to the office for students
which is um
the university's regulator in england um
by theresa may and um because i was a
political appointee
um to a public role um you know um all
the enemies of the government kind of
decided to kind of do some offense
archaeology on me
looking at everything i'd said or
written or tweeted you know dating back
to
the 80s and um one person literally
dredged up something i'd written in 1987
which was 31 years earlier
and uh and of course because i've been a
you know a a journalist kind of um and a
fairly kind of provocative controversial
journalist for more than 30 years it
didn't take them long to find unsuitable
material um and
so i stepped down from that position
after about a week you know
the urging of various government
ministers and officials um and uh and
then you know um the mob then came for
me and all my other positions and i
ended up having to step down from five
positions in total including my
full-time job which paid the mortgage
and um and that was kind of a an
unpleasant experience um and one of the
really unpleasant things about it is
that there was no organization to turn
to for kind of good professional
guidance you know if i stepped down is
that going to help or is that going to
make things worse should i resign or
force them to fire me should i apologize
or or will that just be like you know
blood in the water um uh you know who do
i turn to for good psychological
counselling and some people you know
when they're faced with being targeted
by an outrage mob find it really
psychologically dramatic one of the
things we've found at the free speech
union so i thought afterwards you know
after the kind of dust had settled and i
recovered i thought why not set up an
organization that can help people that
find themselves in this situation i mean
you think you can rely on your friends
and to a large part you can i mean
luis louis uh ck came up with a good
line which he got cancelled obviously um
uh he said um people tell you that when
something like this happens you find out
who your real friends are and that's
true but it's the wrong half
in my case it wasn't the wrong half most
of my friends did stick by me but people
are a bit reluctant to kind of stand up
and defend you in public for fear that
you know then the mob will target them
so to have a kind of professional
organization there to do that for you
and offer you advice and put a kind of
protective shield around you i thought
that would be you know a really helpful
service something that was really needed
and that was really the inspiration for
the free speech union and
what people think and get wrong about
the free speech union is they think it's
just about helping people like
celebrities etc radio presenters but
that's not the vast majority of the work
that you do no the vast majority of the
people we help are ordinary people um
you know from all walks of life so for
instance um we recently came to the aid
of a um west midlands train driver a guy
called jeremy sleath um a corbinista
actually um and he on on freedom day
july 19th last year
he said on his private facebook account
um thank god the pubs are reopening i
didn't want to live in a muslim
alcohol-free caliphate for the rest of
my life
and one of his colleagues complained he
was investigated and fired for gross
misconduct
for something he said you know some a
mildly provocative not terribly funny
gag on his private facebook account that
was enough to get him fired from his job
as a train driver and he came to us for
help we raised some money um we took his
uh case to the employment tribunal and
we successfully got um
a judgment of unfair dismissal and now
they're agreeing the compensation he
should be paid yet people like that is
the people that come to us for help
ordinary people not big celebrities like
jk rowling who can look after themselves
toby before we get onto the online harms
bill which i think is really really
important for us to talk about really
important
i just as a as a curious aside we've
seen in the last few days uh elon musk's
impending takeover of twitter if it does
in fact happen because it still hasn't
been finalized
as a general secretary of the free
speech union what do you make of sort of
one man taking over one of the crucial
platforms in which public debate happens
and of course i think he's expressed
some principles that the three of us
would agree with
but the principle of one person having
that much control are you are you
optimistic are you concerned are you
both like where where do you sit on yeah
i'm not kind of um
too troubled by the fact that you know
one guy is exercising this extraordinary
influence um you know you could say the
same about mark zuckerberg and facebook
um but i am troubled by mark zuckerberg
okay but it's not people people people
objecting to it or objecting as though
something like this has never happened
before this is an unprecedented
um uh uh example of one man yes
exercising this extraordinary influence
when you know
social media companies successful
internet companies search engines
they're all owned by you know a handful
of billionaires so you know okay you can
change the system um but there's nothing
kind of particularly unusual or sinister
about what's just happened and actually
in a way i think it's an example of
capitalism working the way it should not
an indictment of capitalism you know
it's a market correction there are all
these big tech social media companies
search engines which are pretty much all
progressive in one
one form or another um so it's great
that someone's come in who doesn't share
that agenda necessarily and believes
more strongly in free speech um you know
that's an example of a market correction
so you know i i think it's a good thing
um
whether he'll actually kind of turn
twitter into the platform we'd all like
it to be remains to be seen what i hope
he'll do
is rather than overhaul twitter's
content moderation policies um uh i hope
that um he'll outsource the content
moderation so essentially say to people
look it's up to you to
censor what you want to censor it's up
to you if you want to take a risk if you
say i don't mind being exposed to
misinformation or hate speech uh then
you know
then then
what they see on twitter needn't be
filtered if they want to just have civil
grown-up respectful conversations about
important public policy issues then they
can turn all the filters on so they kind
of screen out the trolls but it should
be up to the individual as to the risk
they're prepared to take it shouldn't be
imposed upon them top down by you know
content moderators in silicon valley so
i i hope that's the i hope that's the
way forward toby when you said if they
want civil discussions i'm like get off
twitter
that's what you need to do
you could you could create a kind of you
know um a sub community within twitter
which is kind of um
in which people kind of voluntarily um
screen out the kind of loud
you know brash vulgar voices people just
have basically yes
grown up conversations
sorry no i was going to say um so let's
talk about the online harms bill because
this is what we've come to talk about
primarily yeah so let's get into it
what's the problem today well what is it
first what is it and what is the problem
with it so the online harms bill it's
not called the it's not called the um uh
uh
online safety bill um but it began life
as an as as the uh online harms white
paper a few years ago
and sajid javid when he unveiled that
white paper said his aim was to make
britain the safest place in the world to
go online which you know
sounds to me like the most regulated
place in the world if you want to set up
a social media company anyway um uh so
it began life there and it was partly in
response to kind of a moral panic about
um the uh
chil
how the internet was and social media
was harming children causing them to
self-harm in some cases commit suicide
providing them with access to drugs and
pornography and so on and so forth so a
moral panic about how children were
being kind of corrupted led astray
harmed by you know the wild west and um
and so they brought it in and it's now
kind of it's now kind of gone through a
kind of evolutionary process and the
latest iteration of it is the second
draft of the online safety bill um and
i'll set out the kind of initial case
against it then let's try and steal man
the online safety bill and i'll then try
and set out the case for it from a free
speech point of view and incredibly
there is a free speech argument for it
and nadine doris has made that argument
so we'll look at that and then
tell you why i don't think the free
speech case as she's making it for the
bill is very compelling
um that doesn't sound too much like a
40-minute lecture so the kind of keep it
to 20.
so um so on the face of it the reason
for concern um is that um
it will create a duty of care
it will impose this new legal duty on
social media big social media companies
search engines
google facebook twitter youtube
whereby
those companies will have to remove
harmful content and by which they mean
not just content that's harmful to
children but also content that is
harmful to adults
um and um if they fail to do so they can
be fined by ofcom who will be empowered
as the new internet regulator they can
be fined ten percent of their annual
global turnover so when you're looking
at companies like facebook google
twitter that's a huge that's billions of
dollars so uh uh
social media companies search engines
will have a powerful financial incentive
to remove harmful content and the really
sinister thing is that um it won't just
be uh content that's unlawful that
they'll be obliged to remove um it'll
they'll also be obliged to remove what
has been called legal but harmful
content so stuff you can say offline you
won't be able to say online so the fact
that it's legal doesn't mean it won't be
prohibited um
and often the stuff that the big social
media companies will end up removing
which is perfectly law
perfectly lawful will be stuff you know
that that lobby groups activists are
complaining about uh they'll say this is
harmful to the lgbtq plus community um
or this is harmful to you know recently
arrived migrants or whatever it is uh
and and the company is kind of fearful
that they might be fine you know these
huge amounts by ofcom will er on the
side of removal uh censorship um so
that's the reason for concern it's gonna
it's it's it's been described as a kind
of census charter and um it means that
um stuff you'll be able to say you know
in other countries you won't be able to
say here online um uh it'll be you know
one of the most censorious heavily
regulated you know environments for
social media companies and search
engines if they want to operate in the
uk okay um so that's the sort of that's
the sort of standard that's the case
against it what is the case for it from
a free speech point of view well i made
a couple of notes on the on the train on
the way here trying to kind of think
about um how to steel man this from a
free speech point of view um so nadine
doris um makes the following arguments
and her ministers in favor of the bill
from a free speech point of view they
point out that one of the things the
bill will do
will be to repeal various communications
offences such as the malicious
communications act which free speech
campaigners have been campaigning
against for some time um the uh
communications offence under which um
count dankula yeah was prosecuted
that'll be repealed
um and it'll those communications
offences will be replaced by a new
harm-based communications offence um
which is um instead of looking at the
subject matter of the unlawful
communication or the communication to
determine whether it's unlawful or not
they'll look at the effect it has the
psychological effect it has on the
recipient um and um it'll be unlawful
it'll be an unlawful uh unlawfully
harmful communication if it causes
psychological harm amounting to at least
serious distress if the person sending
the message intended to cause harm like
to a likely audience and the person has
no reasonable excuse for sending the
message and nadine doris and her
ministers argue that this new harm-based
communications offence because it's
replacing all these other communications
offences which free speech campaigners
like me don't like um it'll actually
create a more permissive environment
than the one we're currently in so from
a free speech point of view we should
welcome
those
that particular cluster of reforms which
were included in the bill um she also
says and she said this on twitter
yesterday i think in a debate with
fraser nelson that there's nothing in
the bill as it stands to force social
media companies to remove legal but
harmful content um
all they'll have to do is if they is
agree terms and conditions with ofcom
and in those terms and conditions yes
they'll be obliged to pledge to remove
unlawful content but they won't be
required by law
under this bill to remove legal but
harmful content if they want to do that
they can
so if they want to say if twitter
probably not twitter now facebook if
facebook wants to say we're going to
prohibit this content because even
though it's lawful we think it's harmful
they'll be able to do that but subject
to a couple of provisos one of the
provisos is that they have to give
special protection to content of
democratic importance and journalistic
content we'll get onto that in a minute
and when removing content from their
platforms when removing lawful content
they have to have regard for freedom of
speech and nadine dory says um that you
know i'm not gonna force these social
media companies at least not in this
bill um to remove legal but harmful
content the only thing they'll be
obliged to do will be to remove unlawful
content if they want to go beyond that
they can
but they have to uh do it subject to
these various caveats which will protect
free speech and she argues that this is
the first time social media companies
have had these free speech duties
imposed upon them so it's a better place
from a free speech point of view than
we're in at the moment
and then um the final argument um the
final pro free speech argument is that
um once a social media company has
agreed its t's and c's with ofcom offcom
will then hold that company's feet to
the fire when it comes to enforcing
those policies so it'll have to enforce
them consistently and non-arbitrarily
and not in a politically biased way and
she argues that that'll make it
impossible for twitter for instance in
future to remove trump from the platform
but not the leader of the taliban or
vladimir putin um that that social media
companies won't be able to
selectively you know apply their
community standards and say
trigonometry's interview with kathleen
stock has breached youtube's community
standards but navarro media's interview
with george galloway hasn't you know
they'll have to be consistent um and in
that way uh that that that will
protect free speech and eliminate
political bias on social media platforms
so that that sort of that's that's the
case for it from a free speech point of
view and i think
let me just go back over those arguments
to tell you why i don't think any of
them are particularly um compelling um
so um
yes
uh i think the repeal of various
communications offenses uh and the
replacement of them by a harm-based
communications offence um yes that's in
some ways attractive it's more
attractive than where we are now and i
think it probably will be a little bit
more permissive fewer people will be
prosecuted i mean not many people are
prosecuted now but even fewer in all
likelihood will be prosecuted uh for
communications offences in future once
this bill becomes law
but the shortcoming of this approach of
defining um
unlawful communications
by looking at the impact they have on
the recipient
psychological harm likely to cause
extreme distress is it kind of it's it
it's creating this kind of
responsibility for the state to protect
people from psychological harm and i
think that is a very dangerous precedent
and not not something the state should
be in the business of doing well not
least because psychological harm is
entirely subjective well that's the
subjectivity argument you know how we're
going to measure it well we francis
could discuss both of our hairlines and
we could you know one of us could be
deeply offended by another one
considered as a joke yeah right and and
it says and it it it says that um if
it's likely to cause psychological harm
amounting to extreme distress to a
likely audience so on you know on
twitter you say something you think
you're just saying it to your followers
but if one of them retweets it and they
then retweet it it goes viral it ends up
you know in the um on the screen of an
extremely kind of psychologically
fragile person it could actually cause
them extreme distress
but um you know why should you be held
responsible for that
um so yeah i think the idea that the
state
should be in the business of protecting
people from psychological harm and as
you say it it it it's a sort of gold
embossed invitations to activists and
lobby groups say that's psychologically
harmful that made me feel unsafe who are
you to say that uh my distress isn't
serious distress is it because i'm a uh
you know is it because i'm a trans
person that you're not taking my
distress seriously you can just imagine
a kind of you know a cascade of demands
to remove content on the grounds that
it's causing people who are quite
psychologically fragile extreme
psychological distress so that that's
extremely dangerous and a really uh
dangerous precedent i think um but okay
even setting that aside um uh uh
when i when when when me and the chief
legal counsel of the free speech union
had a conversation with one of the
ministers and some senior officials in
the department for culture media and
sport about the bill they offered this
as a kind of quid pro quo yes you know
in some respects free speech will get
worse
because of this bill but in others it'll
get better and look we're repealing the
malicious communications act you must be
happy about that well yes but one
interesting thing is that these these
these um reforms to communications law
will only apply in england and wales um
they're not gonna because
you know communications offenses are a
devolved
area of legislation so they won't apply
in scotland they won't apply in northern
ireland in scotland you could be in the
worst of all possible worlds in which
you know um uh companies social media
companies could be prosecuted find
billions of dollars um for um uh uh uh
posting or allowing people to post
content that's harmful under these old
communications laws um so so you know
it and it's gonna it's kind of like an
analog bill for a digital age in that
respect to create kind of a different
regulatory environment in england and
wales to the regulatory environment in
scotland and northern ireland i mean
it's going to be an incredible headache
for someone who wants someone who wants
to set up a complete you know
a competitor to twitter or facebook
they're going to have to get their heads
around you know the unbelievable
patchwork quilt complexity of
regulations in the uk there won't even
be one standard for the uk it'll depend
whether you're in scotland northern
ireland or england and wales i mean it's
ludicrous um toby before we go like yep
this is a conservative government
this is a conservative government
bringing this in if you know we're in an
alternate universe and corbyn won and
they brought this in i well i'd be
looking like this makes complete sense
what's going on well and and um
that's absolutely true um it's it's it's
baffling that a conservative government
that claims to
um believe in free speech um uh and you
know a a small state
um should be bringing in this
sledgehammer of a bill which is going to
have an unbelievably chilling effect on
free speech online and and one
particular interesting you bring up
bring up corbin you know nadine's
argument that nothing in this bill will
force social media companies to remove
legal but harmful content well that's
true but it's uh it's it's um it's quite
a um a dishonest argument because what
the bill does is it creates an
opportunity a mechanism for the
secretary of state at dcms
currently nadine doris to um
um bring forward supplementary
legislation probably in the form of a
statutory instrument um identifying what
what are called in the bill priority
harms those are things that social media
companies will have to remove as a
matter of priority you know they don't
remove them they really will get fined
and it's when it's in that supplementary
legislation in that statutory instrument
that the legal but harmful stuff is
going to be included so it's likely for
instance that social media companies
will be told you have to remove
misinformation as a matter of priority
you have to remove hate speech as a
matter of priority doesn't matter if
it's lawful
if it's harmful according to this
nebulous open-ended definition you'll
have to remove it um so that's where the
real mischief is going to occur in this
supplementary legislation toby what
francis is getting that and we'll get to
the rest of your point in a second is
you know you know boris johnson yeah
right you you you've studied together
we were told and look neither of us is
by the way a big fan but of his uh
this is a a liberal tory
who who wants to reduce the size the
size of the state and and keep us all
free
and then we had two years like we've
just seen
and now this how do you explain that
um i don't think he's a man um uh unduly
constrained by principle
[Laughter]
i mean i think i think he has i think he
has instincts
um but they can be quite easily
overridden i mean i think he i think he
i think he has a libertarian kind of
default
response and i think that's partly why
he didn't want to plunge us into
lockdown initially um you know in
february march 2020 but they were quite
quickly you know um cast aside when he
came under a lot of pressure from
colleagues and officials scientific
advisors to lock us down you know they
proved to be quite fragile principles um
and i think in this case um you know i
don't think he's really applied himself
to the bill i mean quite often the
reason
he he can be easily kind of um bullied
by kind of more authoritarian colleagues
into abandoning his libertarian
instincts is because he hasn't done his
homework he hasn't mastered the brief
you know they'll make a number of
arguments and he won't know what the
counter arguments are so if nadine dory
isn't you know if it comes up in cabinet
she's she's sort of mastered this brief
she'll say no boris no prime minister
it's gonna it can actually um help from
a free speech point of view and she'll
make all the arguments i just summarized
and he won't know what the counter
arguments are um
think i think he's i think i think when
michael gove said back in what 2016 that
he wasn't temperamentally suited
to be prime minister and that's why
michael go
decided to throw his own head into the
ring and withdraw his his support um i
think that's what i think that was what
he was sort of getting at but he he's
quite he's quite kind of he has quite a
short attention span he's not good at
kind of sitting down and going through
his boxes he's not really interested in
the kind of nitty-gritty the minutiae of
kind of policy documents and proposals
and that's why you know i think dominic
cummings referred to refers to him as
trolley because you know his nickname
behind closed doors in downing street is
trolley because he's like a wonky
supermarket trolley that kind of veers
around according to whoever's pushing it
or he's bumped into last you know
maybe that's a slight exaggeration but i
think i think that's the explanation for
why someone like boris who styles
himself this great kind of libertarian
rebel asian falstaffian kind of uh you
know freedom loving you know yeoman why
he is bringing in his government is
bringing in this bill because he doesn't
he's not he's um he's he's easily
bamboozled and easily kind of knocked
off course and his his libertarian
instincts can easily be kind of uh
submerged under all this kind of
pressure and yeah i think that's
probably the explanation for that but
but just back to your corbin point um
because the bill creates an opportunity
for the secretary of state to um uh
come up with these priority harms where
and that's where the legal but harmful
stuff comes in
okay nadine doris may not may not go
completely over the top when she brings
forward her supplementary legislation
and it's debated in the house of commons
it may be reasonable we may think well
actually you know the definition of hate
speech in this in this statutory
instrument isn't too bad you know um but
what's to stop you know a successor you
know let's say kierstama wins the next
general election not out of the question
at this point and appoints chris bryant
or dawn butler um uh as secretary of
state at dcms they would then have the
power under this bill to bring forward
another statutory instrument identifying
all these priority harms that's where we
could really get into a kind of
unbelievably sensory right you have to
legislate for the future possibilities
not future against political change um
you know it's bad enough under a
supposedly liberty loving conservative
government what if we have something
like a corbyn led labor government who
have absolutely no regard for free
speech you know they'll have the powers
at their disposal to impose
unbelievable amounts of censorship on
what we can say online you know it'll be
at their fingertips thanks to this bill
hey constantine what razor do you use i
used russian blade forging fires of oral
mountains hardened in the winters of
siberia purified in the river of the
volga and sold over-the-counter edwards
in moscow is it good no it sheds more
blood than uncle vlad cracking down on
political protest in that case you need
to try harry's razors i use them myself
and look how clean and smooth my face is
yes my face would also be that smooth if
i had no testosterone harry's is
offering an incredible deal where you
get a free trial set of harry's products
which includes one five blade cartridge
foaming shave gel travel blade cover and
a free travel size face wash how much it
will only cost you three pound 95 that's
just three pound 95 which is the cost of
the packaging and the posting this is
good deal yes and all their products are
dermatologically tested and formulated
by harry's experts their skin care
products are alcohol and cruelty free
alcohol-free is this supposed to be good
thing harry's razors have a weighted
handle not a cheap plastic one that you
get in some mainstream and supermarket
brands this gives you greater control
when you're shaving and means you're
less likely to cut and nick your skin
just head to harris.com forward slash
trigger to have your set delivered and
start shave plan that's harry's dot com
slash trigger and it's just 3 pound 95
for a trial set
there are certain elements of the bill
that i do agree with toby for example
the cyber flashing element of it i don't
understand or what why people especially
women should be subjected to people
sending pictures of their genitals for
instance you know protecting kids from
pornography you know we've both been
involved in education that is a massive
problem that not enough people are
talking about yeah so there are elements
of it which i'm actually on board with
what do you think about that i think i
agree i mean i think there are some
aspects of it um which are completely
defensible um like you know prohibiting
cyber flashing though
you get into a slightly gray area when
it's cyber flashing between consenting
adults that'll be prohibited too
um so that's kind of uh
should we prohibit that you know why
shouldn't be able to send a dick pic to
kind of um mrs foster you know if
because i'm socially conservative that's
why
that should only be kept for a darkened
bedroom yeah but i think i think that
the the um the clauses of the bill which
are intending to protect children you
know it's hard to argue with them um but
it's the stuff which is intended to
protect adults from harm including legal
content that's the kind of really
pernicious dangerous sensorial stuff
that's going to have a chilling effect
on free speech why should the government
be able to decide on my behalf what i
can and can't see you know if it's
lawful you know it's one thing for
parliament to pass laws you know
in a democratic process to prohibit
certain things you know
that's one thing you can argue with that
maybe majority shouldn't be able to
impose their kind of moral values on
minorities and so forth but you know
that's one thing but that isn't this
they're saying that even if a law hasn't
been passed prohibiting certain certain
content on social media we will we will
we will insist that social media
companies remove it nevertheless under
threat of being fined 10
of their annual global turnover and
that's like well why why that's
completely undemocratic and um you know
um why shouldn't i be able to decide um
what lawful content uh i'm able to see
you know on my phone on my social media
platforms well toby the argument and i i
do actually think for all my strong
support for the idea of freedom of
speech of course you know my position on
it at the same time i think the argument
now is the harm side of these things is
becoming more prominent because as these
networks become bigger and they connect
more and more people the concern is and
it's not the example i'm about to give
is not one in which i particularly
share their analysis but i can see a
similar example in which that would be
the case is the banning of donald trump
at the very beginning of 2021 and the
argument from the social media companies
was uh this was an election in the most
powerful country in the world with tons
of nuclear weapons and it seemed to them
i don't agree with this interpretation
but it seemed to them that there was
essentially an attempt to overthrow the
lawful
lawfully elected candidate by storming
the capital again i don't agree with
that interpretation but that's how they
saw it and they felt that
given the potential for huge
calm that could come from lawful
activity it's not unlawful to say on
twitter that you think the election is
illegitimate or whatever it's not
against the law you're allowed to if you
if you and i went down the pub you could
you could say that right that's not
against the law but the impact of
someone with i don't know 70 million
followers
saying that over and over and over they
argue caused people to get to that
position where they are storming the
capital and people die in the process
isn't that something that whether you
like it or not whether i like it or not
we do have to reckon with that ideas are
powerful things and connecting billions
of people together in a place where they
can say things of that nature has real
world impact and as a society like it or
not we're gonna have to have some kind
of reckoning with that
well i think um
i would accept that um a limit should be
placed on free speech um whereby people
shouldn't be free to say things which
are likely to
um result uh imminently in violence you
know i think that that's a legitimate
constraint restriction on free speech
and maybe you could argue
that that was a good reason that was the
rationale for banning trump from twitter
what he was saying you know on the eve
of the attack on the capital was
inciting violence uh and that and yeah
if it was then maybe that was a good
reason um but i think the difficulty
with removing stuff you know people
saying we think the election was stolen
for instance after trump's been removed
from the platform um is that um actually
that's not
it's i think it's hard to make the case
that that's likely to lead to imminent
right user 7345 saying the election was
stolen isn't causing the capital right i
think there was the argument that
um uh i think louis brandeis who was a
supreme court justice made in a famous
case i think in the 1950s in which he
said the um uh cure for bad information
is not to suppress that information the
cure is more information sunlight is the
best disinfectant and the problem with
banning stuff that you think is
misinformation or is likely to
cause insurrection
is that
by banning it you're not reducing its
toxicity you know you're forcing it
underground you're forcing it on into
kind of darker corners of the internet
you know people who who are kind of
inclined to be triggered by that stuff
are probably going to find it anyway
isn't it better that it should be on you
know larger more mainstream platforms
where it can be challenged openly you
know if you if you think the election
was stolen um uh you know in you and you
make that argument on twitter and
twitter bans it that's going to persuade
you that you're right and that's why it
was banned it can persuade other people
seeing that ban that there's actually
something to it because otherwise why
would they ban it they're obviously
scared they've got something to hide
whereas if you let them say it and then
rebut it with a kind of overwhelming
number of kind of facts with a kind of
mountain of evidence to show it isn't
true um then it's likely to kind of lose
a lot of its power and lose a lot of its
influence i think that sunlight is the
best disinfectant that's a really good
argument against suppressing even
dangerous misinformation i agree with
you in in principle i really really do
and i'm obviously playing devil's
advocate and trying to explore the
argument here but
one of the things we do see on social
media is that isn't what happens
when somebody says i think this
it's not that there's an overwhelming
barrage of counter information it's that
everyone's in their own silo now and
what happens is people who think a and
people who think b are just in different
spaces talking to themselves now and so
you're not getting that traditional idea
of if we're all in a meeting with 300
people and you stand up and you go i
think covert is caused by 5g and we need
to go and blah blah blah
and
200 other people stand up and go you're
an idiot and here's why and blah blah
that's what you're talking about but
that's not what happens on social media
what happens on social media is one
person stands up and says something 200
other people agree who already agree and
they never see the people who don't
agree with them i think that's a slight
caricature i mean you know we're all on
twitter sometimes you do see you know um
quite grown-up kind of well-informed
quite sophisticated nuanced debate is
taking place of course between people on
completely opposite sides of big
contentious issues and you know you see
it on facebook too you see it uh you see
it on youtube you know it it's uh of
course there are kind of people who
don't want to hear the other side and
but i think it's hard to blame social
media for that i think you know we've
naturally just become a more kind of
politically polarized uh society both
here and in america and elsewhere and
you know social media may have
accentuated that but you know it's not i
don't think it's the root of the problem
um i think there's another argument too
the argument against um uh banning hate
speech so the argument for banning hate
speech is that if you don't you allow
these kind of toxic flowers to bloom and
um they could result in kind of
unpleasant people getting elected um
populist revolts and so on and so forth
um but um uh in jacob matrum gama's
recent book on free speech was a history
of free speech he makes this really good
observation um about uh weimar germany
and he probably know this but in weimar
germany various forms of hate speech
such as anti-semitism were criminalized
and
various kind of prominent nazis actually
spent time in jail for producing you
know publishing anti-semitic material
hitler was banned for large parts of the
1920s
in various um german states um uh
and none of that uh did anything to
undermine the kind of um appeal and
growth of the nazi party on the contrary
it allowed them to cast themselves as
martyrs at odds with this kind of
oppressive state that was kind of
suppressing what they had to say because
it was true you know it had the opposite
of its intended effect i think that's
generally if you do try and suppress
these right wing toxic points of view
you know you don't you don't stave off
another kind of nazi victory at an
election you make it more likely
and
we keep using the word harm how do they
define this word
got the definition i wrote it down here
it's um uh yeah uh psychological harm um
amounting to at least serious distress
but unless what see this is the problem
because what are you going to do
everybody who then makes a complaint are
you going to have a psychiatrist come in
and give them some kind of psychiatric
assessment
or how how do you define this there's no
requirement for for a clinical
assessment now i think it'll be
subjectively defined if someone claims
that a a post that they've read has
caused them
extreme psychological distress then
you'll have to take that at face value
but so but let's flip it over
and look at it another way so my
mother's venezuelan socialism has been a
disaster in my country one of my cousins
literally drinks rain water from the
tank on top of his house because the
water the running water in his house is
so polluted that if he drinks it
it could very literally make him
incredibly even kill him
so what someone puts a post advocating
socialism on facebook i go i'm
distressed take it down well um i guess
this is where the um protections for
content of democratic importance come in
i mean that that
that this is one of the great the
nadine doris and the defenders of the
bill make great play of this if you want
to make a political argument doesn't
matter if it causes people extreme
psychological distress it'll be
protected because it's content of
democratic importance and we don't want
to censor those important democratic
debates
then the question becomes well who gets
to decide
what's uh content of democratic
importance and what isn't you know um
there was that recent uh truck the maya
force data the first meyer false data
employment tribunal in which the judge
used this very sinister phrase in which
he said that gender critical views
weren't deserving of respect in a
democratic society so you know according
to that you know judge honor
the member of the employment tribunal
you know he he didn't think that was
content of democratic importance now you
know um uh that that judgment was um
overturned in part by the employment
appeals tribunal and now the employment
tribunal is taking place again and we
don't know what the outcome of that will
be but you know
for a figure of considerable authority
to declare no
that isn't content of democratic
importance because gender critical
beliefs are not deserving of respect in
a democratic society you can imagine
that kind of argument being made over
and over again and you know do we
how much do we trust ofcom to get that
kind of thing right don't forget melanie
dawes uh the chief executive of ofcom
said a couple of years ago that she
didn't think that it was appropriate to
feature anyone from the lgb alliance on
a bbc news or itv news discussion about
the gender recognition act because their
views were beyond the pale you know and
okay she's revised that position now but
how confident can we be that offcom
isn't going to make similar errors of
judgment when it comes to deciding what
issues are deserving of this protection
because they're of democratic importance
and what aren't you know i i certainly
don't trust them i'd like personally to
be able to make that decision myself and
not trust to a regulator to make it on
my behalf i mean there's another problem
as well with protecting journalistic
content you know who gets to decide
who's a journalist right are we
journalists is this journalism content
you know
we'd have to ask offcom you know are
they gonna come up with
what they might say
will you have to be regulated by ipso or
impress you know
and if you do that's a way of bringing
in state regulation of of the press you
know until now um regulation of the
press has been voluntary um and there
was a huge battle that me and others
fought to prevent it becoming you know
regulated by a state regulator in the
mar in the aftermath of the leveson
inquiry and we won that battle but this
looks like it's coming that's coming
back now through the back door if they
if they can if if in order to be
entitled to this protection journalistic
content you have to be registered in
some way you have to satisfy you've got
to be on the right
i've been reassured that there won't be
kind of a list of approved you know
journalists and a list of kind of
dangerous journalists um that all you'll
have to do to satisfy
ofcom that you are a legitimate provider
of journalistic content you need to have
a proper complaints policy and an
opportunity for people who think they've
you know been misrepresented to reply
you have to offer people a right of
reply you have to have a proper
uh policy about how you deal with
complaints and factual corrections and
you have to correct them and so forth
you don't have to be registered you
don't have to be regulated by you know a
regulator like that that's what they say
but you know all these things can be
kind of changed as soon as the bill
becomes law you know by a small
amendment so that's all quite scary i'm
very aware that you have to to run uh so
we won't hold you too much longer but
you the way you're talking about it it
sort of sounds to me like you've
accepted that this bill is going to pass
right well what can people do before we
let you go about this is there and do
they write to their mp do they you know
find out more from like what's what do
we do well
um i think politically um it is gonna
happen i think it's it's a it's a huge
mountain to climb to actually derail
this now i mean maybe that's not
impossible
but it feels like that's kind of
unrealistic it's gonna happen there's a
lot of political momentum there's a lot
of support for the bill
in the house of commons even though the
conservatives have an 80 seat majority
go figure um so what can we do well we
can try and improve it and what the free
speech union is doing is working with a
number of lawyers and other lobby groups
in this space to try and come up with a
raft of amendments to make the bill
better so i referred earlier to this
duty that the bill will impose on social
media companies to have regard for
freedom of speech when making a decision
about whether to remove
you know harmful content um but half
regard is the weakest of the legal
duties so you know twitter could say
we've been told that jk rowling's posts
are causing serious psychological
distress to trans people
we've considered the free speech
implications of banning jk rowling from
the platform and entirely dismissed them
without a second thought
that would be satisfying the duty to
have regard for freedom of speech it
requires you to do no more than just
think for a second about the free speech
implications and then entirely dismiss
them um so one thing we want to do the
the the biggest amendment the one we
really hope we'll get through is to
strengthen that duty so it becomes
something just a little bit more
onerous like have particular regard for
freedom of speech we want that duty to
be on the same
have the same status the same legal
force as the duty of care and if we can
do that that would go some distance
towards improving the bill i think
another way you could kind of in order
to con you could say that let's amend
the new communications offence so in
order to convict someone under this new
harmful communications
offense um you have to show that the
person in the likely audience that was
psychologically seriously distressed by
this um didn't consent
to to it so you know if you if you build
a consent clause into that you know a
person can't be prosecuted if all the
members of the likely audience they
thought it would end up who'd end up
receiving the message if they'd all
consented to if you had reasonable
grounds for assuming they consented to
it and then you can build in a bit of
this kind of you know what i was talking
about earlier kind of
with people deciding for themselves what
they can and can't see and you could say
look i i just assumed that everyone that
was going to see this message had
consented to kind of you know um uh
being in the kind of wild west category
um and if they're not in that category
then they it shouldn't have been sent to
them it shouldn't have been passed on to
them and that's the person you should go
after not me
what does this mean for comedy toby well
um uh
nadine doris said
she actually gave as an example jimmy
carr's
um joke about gypsies and the holocaust
as an example of legal but harmful
content that this bill would prohibit
so yeah she actually
on a particular joke
and said that's the kind of thing
this bill is going to put a stop to so
yeah comedians should be seriously
concerned so hang on a second so people
will be able then to let's say they
watch jimmy carr special
they will then be able to go after
netflix as a result of this well i think
netflix will be covered under a new
similar bill which will apply a similar
regulatory regime to on demand
let's translate it into facebook twitter
terms if someone took that clip yeah and
put it on twitter on facebook and shared
it yeah they could be liable to be
prosecuted well the the the
the the platform um which didn't remove
it as soon as someone asked for it to be
removed they would be liable for
prosecution so they would never let that
be published
no no all right so we're getting to the
point of content so we're getting to the
point where the government is going to
censor comedians jokes basically yeah
yeah well ofcom will be in the business
of of censoring jokes yes yeah and i've
met melanie dawes and she doesn't strike
me as having a particularly good sense
of humor
so that's reassuring
but
i mean that's that could be unfair
actually
forget about her i don't give a [ __ ]
about her sense of humor we're talking
about a government body or a state body
deciding what jokes are allowed to be
told yeah which is ridiculous
yeah and
yeah the critical thing is the
government through ofcom the state will
be deciding
what jokes it thinks you should be able
to hear and what jokes you shouldn't it
it's putting itself in the business it's
like the lord chamberlain of old
deciding what plays can be put on the
west end and what can't because some
people have to be protected what if your
servants read lady chatterley's lover
what the [ __ ] would it have on them you
know the state is resurrecting
this this um
responsibility to protect people from
their own worst instincts to stop them
from seeing legal content but could be
harmful they're not the best judges of
whether that's going to harm them cause
them psychological distress or not what
effect it's likely to have on their
behavior and their families no we are
the best judges of that and we get to
decide and so what
where is netflix in all of this then
well i think there's a separate media
bill which will um regulate
on-demand streaming
services like netflix i don't think
netflix is within scope of this
particular i think youtube is but
netflix isn't but there's another but
because of that they've got this other
bill ready um which is which is going to
kind of mean that they can regulate
ofcom can regulate netflix um you know
apple tv plus disney plus etc so
eventually it's going to be the
government dictating what you can and
can't say online what you can and can't
laugh at what
yeah and the interesting thing is that
you'll be able to say it on you'll be
able to make the dangerous joke on stage
provided someone doesn't film it and
then put it up online it just you just
won't be able to make the same joke
online no stuff which it's lawful to say
won't be lawful to type after this bill
because but then that has an effect on
people's psyche because well we all now
spend so much time online so that is
going to then filter into real life well
there is a there is a there is a quick
fix
vpn you know if you can access the
internet using a vpn which which places
you you know in florida
rather than london then you'll be able
to see all this unregulated content i
mean what it will mean effectively is
that if you're accessing
all this content from the uk
um or rather from england and where
depends where you are in the uk as you
said earlier but if you're here and
you're trying to access that content
there's lots of stuff you won't be able
to see that you would be able to see if
you lived somewhere else almost anywhere
else but particularly in america um so i
think i think there'll be a massive
surge in the use of vpns because people
just won't want
the government to protect them in the
way it's proposing to do
well that is quite a sobering thought
toby uh listen thank you so much for
coming back i'm sure this is an issue
we'll be talking more and more about
because i find that really really
genuinely troubling it is it's really
scary it's the it's the greatest blow to
freedom of speech i think of our
generation and it's a really significant
battle and i would just urge people who
want to join this battle to join the
free speech union and help us wage that
battle
toby thank you so much we're going to
ask you a couple of questions from our
supporters for our supporters before we
let you go but thank you for joining us
and thank you for watching and listening
we'll see you very soon with another
interview or raw show all of them go out
at 7 pm uk time while we're still
allowed exactly and for those of you who
like your trigonometry on the go it's
also available as a podcast and that's
probably going to be [ __ ] as well take
care and see you soon guys
we have to persuade young people for
social justice reasons as a webster you
know you should be defending free speech
[Music]